6 12 it is Wednesday morning and it's
Pro Bowl week here in Las Vegas events
get started tomorrow we've got the
shrine bull happening that features the
nation's best college football players
but the football fund goes beyond
Allegiant Stadium it's all over town
there are lots of events going on off
and on the Strip Candace Charles is live
this morning at Topgolf with a look at
its Pro Bowl plans over there she's
staying warm by dancing around with her
Golf Club what's going on Candace
Sherry you hit this on the nose because
really I am quite cold so it's good to
dance here because there's always great
music and you can watch the game here
and get your shot at winning some money
for the big game I had Dwayne gallucci
here from Rampart Casino thank you so
much for joining me tell us a little bit
about the Pro Bowl what do you think is
going on with that any odds a little bit
that you have details for folks well a
little different this year I have to say
it's at Allegiant so it's definitely a
popular attraction but we're having a
different format so we don't have
wagering as of yet but we do have Super
Bowl and big game wages let's talk that
that's that's really what people want to
know tell us where the odds can people
get in for like as low as five bucks how
much can people make oh you could bet as
little as five dollars and definitely I
would recommend betting player props on
the big game when you're dealing with
five dollar Wagers because if you bet
five dollars on the Chiefs or you bet on
Philadelphia you're only going to make
four dollars and change so I always say
have fun with it if you're an amateur
Gambler if you're a professional
naturally they'll be laying more bigger
Wagers down on the big game all right
doing you know what I gotta say
I think I want to bet you right now
we're going to do a little bit are you
ready for this bets I'm ready okay ready
I'm gonna bet you that I can actually
hit this ball that's as far as I'm gonna
go guys uh we'll see if we can take a
sweat right away
all right here we go I've been
practicing on the T Miss Charles
wait oh no
there it is
listen I was practicing and Stacy a
great photographer actually helped me he
taught me a little bit but the way yes
you won that bet thank you so much
thank you so much for joining us this
morning you guys we got you covered with
more details on our website newsnow.com